hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll remember when we talked about
the social construction of reality
wasn't that fun
we contrasted this human scale way of
thinking about the world the social
world where you make up categories and
then they're they're based on what
really happens but there's a lot of
freedom there we contrasted that with
the physics level right with the
electrons and the photons where it's
pretty clear how you want to think about
the pieces out of which reality is made
but there are a lot of layers in between
the physics level and the social level
the human level right there's all of
biology for example today we're going to
dig into a puzzle or at least an
important research area within biology
that involves exactly this what is the
right way to
conceptualize the world of species and
populations and evolution
famously richard dawkins in the 1970s
popularized a view known as the selfish
gene
back in the old days in the beginning of
the theory of evolution you might have
focused on individual organisms and
imagined these organisms wanted to
reproduce their own genomes right they
wanted to have kids and have their
genetic heritage be passed on to future
generations
then came the math then came a way of
thinking about population genetics that
pointed out that you can pass on the
genes inside of you even without you
being involved if all of your relatives
are very good at passing on genes so it
became not only dawkins but other people
point out that it's as if
it's the genes that want to pass on
their heritage not the individuals
carrying them in fact you could say that
the individuals are just kind of a bus
full of genes they're a vehicle that
carries on the genes because
individuals die right organisms are born
they have a life they die less than a
century for most species whereas the
genes can live on a very very long time
being passed from generation to
generation
so surprisingly not everyone agrees not
so surprisingly of course this is a
complicated thing what is the best way
to conceptualize
levels of selection this is what we call
this particular debate in biology is it
at the level of genes of species of
populations of individuals and it's
exactly this kind of how do you divide
up reality kind of question the answer
from our uh guest today arvid ogren uh
who's worked as a biologist on this
problem is he's actually pretty pro the
selfish gene view or as he calls it the
gene's eye view of evolution but he
completely admits that it's not the
end-all
biology is more complicated as we've
often found out here on mindscape than
something easy like physics is there's
leakage between the levels of genes and
molecules up to organisms up to
populations so there's insight to be
gained by thinking about things from the
selfish gene point of view there's also
insight to be gained by thinking about
higher levels of abstraction it's a
wonderful real world example
of the philosophical questions that we
have about emergence complexity how to
chunk the universe up into pieces that
we can analyze and theorize about so i
think it's a great kind of uh discussion
it's very mindscaping as i make the joke
in the podcast both me and the evil sean
carroll the biologist who's a previous
mindscape guest are referenced in
arvid's book so it's a it's a very
natural kind of conversation for us to
have here let's go
[Music]
arvid orgrim welcome to the mind skate
podcast
thank you for having me
so i think we can assume that most of
the audience is familiar with darwinian
evolution theory natural selection and
maybe also a little bit of
mandel and genetics but let's start with
the groundwork at the synthesis of this
these two great ideas right the modern
synthesis it still boggles my mind a
little bit that darwin didn't know about
genetics he went pretty far without
knowing about that but tell us how that
came together in the 20th century yeah
so this is really is one of the kind of
striking moments in the history of
biology what has become known as the the
modern synthesis of biology in the kind
of 1920s 1930s
and as you say this kind of came
together by bringing two different
insights into one theory on the one hand
it was darwin's theory of evolution by
natural selection and a theory about
individual organisms organisms vary in
how well they survive and reproduce and
if any of those traits are
heritable they will become more common
over time
now the big problem for darwin then was
as you say that he had no functioning
theory of uh inheritance and while he
kind of had some high ideas of his own
none of them really came to to work and
that remained a conundrum for him and
kind of viewed as a weakness uh for a
long time of his theory
uh this was in parallel then with the
second
insight that was brought to you and that
was a functioning theory of inheritance
and that was provided by gregor mendel's
work where we the realization that
inheritance function with this
inheritance of these discrete particular
entities which we now refer to as genes
and so i mean if we didn't know about
genes and we didn't know about how
discrete they were clearly there's some
degree of inheritance everyone can see
that in hair color and things like that
but you might have thought that things
would just blend together every time
right and then you would never diverge
everything would just become some kind
of homogeneous uh unified organism or
something like that in terms of you know
sharing the same uh equilibrated
characteristics but with discrete units
all sorts of funny things can happen
exactly and indeed that darwin for a
while believe in is sort of blending
inheritance and that the realization
that you were quickly run out of
variation for national selection to act
upon was a kind of serious issue
for him
and the problem then with this new fear
of inheritance in the form of discrete
entities was that how could that be
reconciled with the gradualism of on one
hand very variants as we see it in the
natural world but also with the
gradualism as envisioned by darwinian
evolution the gradual change over time
and this is really what um the emergence
of population referred to as population
genetics and the idea that you can
describe evolution as changes in certain
variants of genes or allele frequencies
over time so that is what kind of what
evolution almost has come to be defined
as if you open an evolution textbook
today that evolution is changed in
allele frequencies in a population over
time so change is inheritable i guess i
don't quite see how that answers the
question of the apparent smoothness of
variation i would have just said the
variation is smooth because there's a
lot of genes and you can just change one
at a time it looks almost like it's
continuous
and exactly that is what the the
solution that population geneticists uh
found strung upon in particular the uh
the english statistician and evolution
genesis uh ronald fisher showed that you
could get the appearance of gradual
variation from the uh if a trait was
caused by many
alleles with small effects you could get
you can reconcile the gradualism with
the discrete inheritance and that really
represented this major achievement that
was part of kind of this generally
synthesis of bringing together multiple
parts of biology into one and where
i think you already explained it but i'm
going to ask you again to explain the
word allele because it's not exactly the
same as the word gene right
it is not no so allele is a it's like a
version of a gene so for example we may
think of a gene for say uh eye color but
then you can have multiple alleles have
one for blue eyes one for brown eyes for
example so
what we have what we can say we have one
gene for that as a human we have one
allele from our father and one allele
from our mother uh that we have
inherited so i think probably the person
on the street would talk about a gene
for blue eyes or a gene for brown eyes
but really there's one gene for eye
color and there's an allele for brown
eyes or blue eyes yeah
yeah and then in most of the cases you
have many genes with multiple alleles
underlying most traits most of the time
okay very good and what is a gene
i ask everyone i ask every biologist
this question they they always get
uncomfortable when they ask it
is a practical little word uh in biology
that has come to mean quite different
things depending on what corner of
biology you are from
and in kind of theoretical population
genetics it is simply something that
kind of stably inherited something that
you can say affects a trait
and two molecular biologists has a much
more physical or materialistic
definition of it that is the sequence of
uh dna that often has a function or
encodes a protein or rna that does
something
and indeed these kind of multiple
definitions of use of genes within
biology has often led to
misunderstandings and and disagreements
so i guess even when we had mendelian
genetics i mean mendel was still in the
19th century but then
it was sort of glued on or incorporated
into evolutionary theory in the 20th
century uh but we still didn't have dna
at that point right so i mean happily uh
we have dna now did that change the way
we thought about this a lot or did it
just get uh
serving as an underpinning for the
existing discussion about genetics i
think the first approximation changed a
lot in what we think of what genes are
we can study in a completely different
way we have a sense of the number of
genes that that a species has and how
they evolve
and at the same time it is important to
remember that population genetics as a
an approach as a field as you say
emerged before we knew what the material
basis of heritage was before we knew
that it was dna before we knew that dna
was a double helix and those
mathematical models that we still use in
in evolutionary biology were developed
before that before we had any idea of
those and they rely on a definition of a
gene that's completely agnostic about
the material basis and i do think it's
rather remarkable that they work so well
despite being completely
ignorant about what the material base
actually is
except that it let us invent a new
meaning for the word gene right like so
we had the word gene and then we found
dna and then they invented a new meaning
for the word gene namely a sequence of
dna that encodes for a protein
yes yes i mean in the the the population
genetics gene as we use it's still in
population is much closer in a way to
the original mendelian gene as kind of
as it was originally but
um it is certainly one of those words
one of many in biology that
um
have similar enough meaning that people
can think that they are talking about
the same thing but they are different
enough to cause frustration well you've
written a book called the gene's eye
view and what do you mean by the word
gene in the title of your book or does
it not matter
yeah so this inside view uh uses the
word gene in this much more
old-fashioned way of simply defining
something that's stably inherited a part
of a a chromosome that's stably
inherited
across generation
and
this means that it can be almost
arbitrarily
long a gene it can be as anything that's
kind of inherited together which means
that
the parts of the y chromosome for
example that never recombines with the
the x
is a can be thought of as one gene or
kind of large swath circumstance or
indeed very small part of a chromosome
it's also thought of as a gene here but
it is kind of this definition agnostic
about the any sort of material basis and
how do we know how much do we know about
the
genetic composition of let's say the
human genome like does everyone agree
that it's divided into so and so many
genes the human dna
to first approximation yes uh that i
think everyone is in the same order of
magnitude you may
i don't know exactly what the latest
number is when i was taught it it was
somewhere between 20 and 25 000 genes i
think someone who
did you know with the latest updates of
the human genome you're going to find a
more precise
number and i think i'm sure experts
disagree but to first approximation i
think everyone kind of agrees that this
is the number this is all off topic a
little bit but i since i have you here
i'm just sort of satisfying my curiosity
about a bunch of these questions
do we have differential data about the
persistence of different genes over time
i mean are some genes very
malleable over evolutionary time scales
and others stick around
yeah no so i mean certainly we
know that
we have something called pseudogenes
which are genes that are still around
they're still recognized as genes but
they've lost their function in humans so
for example my favorite example
is that we have the gene that allows you
to synthesize vitamin c
from from from scratch which is present
in most mammals yeah but so we have that
gene it's clearly recognizable but it
doesn't work we don't do it uh it's lost
the function so it's in us
some of our primate relatives and i
think in fruit fats that have lost that
ability and carried this around
and so there it's around it hasn't
selection hasn't gotten rid of it right
um but they're also certainly example of
where if you compare species that are
decently related you can see that
they've retained some genes in common
but sometimes they've lost genes or
gained other genes so in my naive
physicist way of thinking about things i
would imagine that
in any stretch of dna there's sort of a
chance per unit generation that a
mutation happens
and in those stretches that really
matter to our functioning
if a bad mutation happens it gets weeded
out it gets selected out of the
population and in
places where it doesn't matter that much
those can just continue to mutate away
so is it true that certain stretches of
dna maintain their integrity
longer than we would think because
they're really really important to us
yeah and indeed that is often how you
know at the heart of the methods that
are used to estimate how much natural
selection is acting across a genome so
if you think of all the dna in an
organism we can ask questions like how
much of this is under constant natural
selection and how much of it is evolving
just by chance or
neutrally as we say which is going to be
a function of things like mutation rate
and population size essentially uh and
this is something like how much
questions like how important is natural
selection versus evolution by randomness
or genetic drift used to be a quite
contentious debate okay in population
genetics but one that has matured a lot
in light of the the abundance of data
that we have now and is much more kind
of uh empirically informed which is much
more
insightful now because we can simply go
out and ask how much of this genome this
the genome in this species is under
selection and so on which we couldn't
before and let me guess the answer is
that some parts selection is really
important in other parts it's not
yeah and in some species most of it is
on reflection in some large sports uh is
is not and um and am i right to think
that maybe in the back of our minds when
we think about selection pressures we're
thinking about you know
some species going out there and hunting
and becoming
faster or stronger and therefore
competing but
really a lot of the selection pressure
is just that if you get the wrong
mutation you die or you're still born
there's you know it's not really that
sort of detailed uh capacity to get food
or or have sex or anything like that
yeah i think that that represents
obviously a crucial part of uh fitness
for any organism but there's so much
more going on in in the life cycle of
any organism a lot of it is that we
can't see or it happens at the molecular
level and often those machineries are
evolutionary old and often quite uh
sophisticated in you know keeping check
that mutation rates are not too high or
kind of the repair mechanisms that are
in place
well i guess so is it
again my naive physicist thing is every
base pair would have a
random chance of mutating uh and then
the selection acts upon those mutations
but is it are there even more
sophisticated
repair mechanisms than that are there
ways biologically or molecular
biologically that uh the really
important parts of dna are protected
from mutation oh that i would i i don't
dare answer that in a confident way um
how that
varies certainly selection is stronger
on on all important parts of the genome
and i think like for example the that we
carry around this gene for vitamin c
where you can kind of accumulate almost
any sort of mutation without selection
doing anything about it how this kind of
the efficacy of the the kind of dna
repair mechanisms vary across the genome
i must i don't know okay i just i'm just
wondering you know if there's in in
quantum computing we care a lot about
what we call error correction right or
even classical communication theory i
can imagine that it'll be evolutionarily
advantageous to develop a
cellular biology level mechanism that
would just say no no i'm not going to
let any mutations happen in this part of
the genome but i have no idea whether or
not that's actually true
no i'm curious too okay good
we'll we'll bring you back if you if you
invent one okay so i think that i
completely interrupted you multiple
times there while you were trying to
explain the modern synthesis what is the
modern synthesis at the end of the day
at the end of the day
the modern synthesis was kind of in a
way the founding of
the field of evolutionary biology as we
know it today it is an event that
brought together rather quite disparate
fields of biology everything from kind
of paleontology to ecology to genetics
into one cohesive science the science of
evolution so on the one hand it was kind
of this crucial event of showing that
mendelian inheritance and darwinian
evolution are compatible and
part of the same process
but in many ways you can also think of
it as a big institutional event that's
when the society for the study of
evolution was founded in the journals
and you know they're starting the
emergence of evolutionary biology as
kind of as a department in university
and
and so on so kind of the modern field of
evolutionary biology was really born in
that
event uh as well it's interesting i
don't think i bet
you don't always see i'm just saying
again i'm completely speculating i
wonder how often i should say you see
a uh
parallel evolution of scientific
knowledge and institutional
support or institutional organization
for thinking about it so you're saying
that in the case of evolutionary biology
they went hand in hand
i i would think so i've recently kind of
come around to this view of that part of
the history of our of the field of
evolution and the is the importance of
the kind of institutional um aspects of
building a new field yeah um and
especially that this was so this kind of
perhaps happened then in the 1940s so
it's just before the emergence of
molecular biology and it was in some
ways you can think of it this is almost
this assault on old-fashioned natural
history organismal-based biology but
it's more modern science which was
considered to be the the future in kind
of uh and um
the recently uh disease uh edwardo
wilson at harvard describes this very
well and he's kind of when he was hired
at the department was then the
department of biology at harvard around
the same time as jim watson co-inventor
of discovery of um the uh double helix
uh and and kind of their battles of what
by all you want to be like
and uh
wilson described this rather nicely in
his autobiography a naturalist and um
that kind of combined with that we have
recently had the 75th anniversary of the
journal of evolution or the evolution
journal uh so it kind of made me reflect
upon that part and the importance of
people like wilson yeah i mean it is
really fascinating because of course we
we hope that science gets at some true
facts about nature but we all know that
it's done by human beings and it's not
just done by individual human beings
right getting support from an
institution having jobs getting funding
all this stuff matters in a really
interesting way
and of course the other thing that
matters that happened i think around
that time is math right i mean once you
were beginning to be thinking about
evolution in terms of population
genetics population is a
number and you can talk about the
fraction of different genes and suddenly
a bunch of equations first on the scene
is very much so in population genetics
remain immunity the theoretical backbone
of evolutionary biology evolutionary
biology i would say is part of biology
that is perhaps the most mathematics
heists and kind of population genetics
um
often borrowed models from from physics
statistical physics and similar kinds of
models describing changes in allele
frequencies from how physicists have
described motion of
objects
uh of course there are other traditions
evolutionary happily stole game theory
from political science and economics and
incorporated perhaps even more
successfully uh as a way of of doing
things and there are also kind of other
kind of quantitative methods for example
in what known as quantitative genetics
where you simply describe changes in
phenotypes over time for example used in
in animal breathing and and so on but i
would say they kind of the emerging
population genetics and during the
modern synthesis was instrumental in in
some ways in making evolutionary biology
be viewed as a more exact science and
something to be taken seriously i mean
it's certainly true that once you write
down equations even if your substantive
content is exactly the same you suddenly
look more respectable because now you
have equations in your papers if you go
oh okay now you're doing serious yeah
especially when you communicate convince
others you are not share the same
obsession as you are that you are to be
taken seriously
can be proven to be quite important and
when we say that there is math i mean
what are the quantities that are being
followed by these equations in physics
you know we have the position and
velocity of particles so what are we
keeping track of and deriving
differential equations for in population
genetics populations have typically been
uh considered kind of the frequencies of
a specific allele in a population and
you kind of you can say if you have an
allele with these properties that has
say this effect on fitness
under what circumstances can it invade
a population so can it become
more common as the generations go by
and also things you're interested in
keeping track of are things like
mutation rate how often does this
mutation happen this specific mutation
uh population size
uh so in large population natural
selection will be more uh effective
whereas in small population chance will
play a big play a bigger role uh if it's
strongly advantageous or what was known
as the selection coefficient so how
how strongly is
this election acting on this specific uh
allele um
those obviously are about the the most
basic parameters and then you can
introduce all sorts of complexities in
terms of population structure and
relatedness between individuals
interacting uh assumptions about the
life cycle where they review sexually or
asexually and how
how mating is determined and kind of
almost any aspect that you're
interested in
but in in kind of traditional population
genetics these are kind of the basic
parameter size mutation rates section
coefficients and so on well that's
interesting i think we're we run
immediately into some philosophy of
science questions here because things
like the um frequency of alleles or the
mutation rate those sound very
measurable you know if i were a
positivist i would say that's good i can
see what's going on there but then you
have some kind of model right some kind
of theoretical uh framework that it fits
into so you already talked about
selection coefficients or uh fitness i
mean maybe explain a little bit more
about what fitness is supposed to be and
and how empirical are those ideas versus
concepts we need to introduce to make
sense of our equations
one of the uh architects of population
genetics the the brit uh jabez holden uh
once described fitness as a bugger it's
one of those kind of uh central uh
entities in evolutionary theory in many
ways you can say we are kind of one
trait discipline at the end of the day
that is what matters
at the same time it is awfully hard to
kind of agree on a proper definition and
even harder to measure in context that
really matters with natural population
usually we think of it as something
along the lines of the genetic
contribution that a given individual
makes to the next uh generation so how
kind of the genes in certain individuals
how much they contribute to the next
generation
um but then we also talk about fitness
of specific
mutations so then we talk about things
that kind of a genic level um we have a
long debate whether it's best to define
fitness
only at the individual level or
sometimes we have notions where we also
should account for the interactions we
have with uh individuals around us this
notion of inclusive fitness
uh
and then you even this is even before we
try to measure anything so right but so
if you those who study kind of evolution
in the wild except for example you want
to compare if you have say you have
sampled individual plants from two
different populations and you put them
in in a third one and see which one has
a have a higher fitness well then you
often have to rely on like well
maybe something like number of seeds
that they produce or kind of maybe even
something like size and all these kind
of indirect measures of of fitness
which means that it is this central
entity that has been a lot of both
conceptual debate how we ought to define
it theoretically but also kind of about
how do you measure it and what are good
kind of indirect measures because that's
usually what we have to rely upon at the
end of the day if you want to study it
in in natural populations when i wrote
my book the big picture i talked about
uh fitness landscapes a little bit i
talked a little about evolution and when
i ran it by some biologists some thought
it was fine others are like why are you
talking about fitness this is an
outmoded concept we can't measure this
this is it's one of the they thought
that it was one of those things that you
know gives you the illusion of
understanding but when uh you get right
down to it it's hard to really quantify
in a reliable way that everyone would
agree on
yeah i think so because often like to do
it well
you would have to keep track of the
features not only of the the focal
individual that you're interested in but
also others in in a population in a way
that's
really quite hard
in the in the in the long run especially
if you study anything other than
plants or um kind of things in in the
lab like you can do it really well with
fruit flies or microbes in a kind of
controlled lab setting we can keep track
of anything but if like i do believe
that at the end of the day what truly
matters in biology try to understand
organisms in natural populations
it is much harder well for one thing
there are things like
floods and earthquakes and asteroids
hitting the planet and you know it's
hard to predict ahead of time what your
fitness is going to be in those
circumstances
yeah pandemics
[Laughter]
okay so but anyway uh to get back to the
main line of thought here we've
mathematized a little bit of population
genetics on the basis of the modern
synthesis and
what we realize it correct me if i'm
wrong my impression from looking at your
book in other places is that um
it's not just about me
and my offspring uh in some sense if
what is if if you can speak of these
goings-on in slightly overly
anthropomorphic language uh what wants
to happen is that your genetic heritage
wants to be shared and one way to do
that is to have kids but the other way
to do it is for your brothers and
sisters to have kids right and so we get
the idea of kin selection and inclusive
fitness
so this is this is a kind of uh
an insight that appears perhaps in like
the generation after the architects of
the modern synthesis so in the 1960s
and at the heart of this is this english
biologist um william bill hamilton
who uh already has a struggling graduate
students write these two
tremendously important papers one
published in 1963 and the other it's a
two-part
majestic piece in like the following
year in 1964.
and there he introduces both
concepts both kin selection which is not
a term that he coined but it was coined
by someone else but which is simply the
idea that selection involves you and the
relatives around you
but at the heart of it was his idea of
inclusive fitness and
to kind of get a sense of why he thought
we needed an update of the basic notion
of fitness you have to think of
situations where the classic definition
doesn't really work
and those often happens in the context
of
social behaviors that we had we had
known for a long time that in social
insects like in bees and ants most you
have individuals that are completely
sterile and instead devote their life to
helping other members of the same
population to reproduce to be the queen
uh this is recognized already by darwin
who described as one special difficulty
of his theory
uh and uh what hamilton realized that
one way to explain this is to think of
that you shouldn't just think about the
organisms the
uh offspring that a specific individual
has but you should also account for
other
offspring that this focal individual is
coarsely responsible for
and you should add those to our focal
individuals fitness scaled by the
relatedness that you have uh to those
individuals so in a way that if your
brother has it that counts for more than
if your cousin does it and so on
and that then it also has to do this to
do the math properly yourself then have
to subtract from this sum the part of
your or the focal individual's personal
fitness that someone else is causingly
responsible for and
doing these kind of sums is where
it can get
messy pretty quickly but that is
basically the heart you end up with this
quantity inclusive fitness that you can
show that individual can appear to
maximize that
then under certain circumstances
inclusive fitness can be maximized even
though this individual does not
personally have any offspring but they
can help enough others to do so and then
still you you can have the process work
but whereby natural selection maximizes
a kind of thickness um but it's a new
definition of it and this is kind of
what emerged in the 1960s and that's the
witty remark from jbs haldane that he
would lay down his life for two brothers
or eight cousins right
exactly exactly that is kind of predates
actually this uh but is uh
very much a
sums up the basic insight very well
by the way just for people who might get
confused out there too i want to mention
two things one is uh you mentioned
william hamilton who is not the famous
mathematician physicist william hamilton
who lived 100 years before uh who
invented hamiltonian mechanics and the
quaternions and things like that two
different william hamiltons also there
are two different sean carrolls and uh
there's a biologist sean carroll and i
when i got when i got your book i think
you will laugh at this when i got your
book i realized that this is a rare book
given that you wrote about
levels of selection and sort of
philosophical things that i care about
but also biology and evolution that the
other schwann cares about this is the
rare book that might have both of us in
the index
and indeed
there is one entry for sean carroll in
the index
but it refers to two different
appearances and one of them is about me
and the other one is about the other one
all right that's great
so it's a very sean carol centric kind
of uh topic that we're talking about
here that's that's what i'd like to see
yeah okay so um
yeah we get the idea that the motivation
for thinking this way i mean maybe the
motivation is that it's true but part of
the motivation is we see in nature
individual organisms
acting in ways other than just trying to
have the most offspring as possible and
and maybe this kin selection or
inclusive fitness can account for that
exactly that that is has been a
tremendously influential way to think
and make sense of these observations
uh it is also a an approach that has
been criticized from from from the
get-go often from mathematically minded
parts of the field and the kind of a
criticism that continues to to this day
that the way
that you it's not as kind of
mathematically robust uh of a construct
as some people with a perhaps a more
mathematical strong background would
like it to be given the centrality that
it has in evolutionary biology right um
it has kind of survived because it
provides a tremendous
powerful rule of thumb and a very
something that kind of empirical biology
fielders can go out and try to guide
their experiments
and to kind of cut this long debate
short in a way my kind of impression of
it is is partly what you want models to
do in evolutionary biology how kind of
comfortable you are with this kind of
mathematical limitations because at the
end of the day this kind of summing up
what
uh at the additivity or summing up what
you are responsible for versus other
parts of the population often is
becomes prohibitively difficult in other
in other cases than the most simple ones
yeah um similarly you have to make
assumptions about
uh genetics and and how strong selection
are and so on to to make it work but
it has pointed us to something really
valuable and that there's one way to sum
up is kind of this the third leg of the
kind of hamiltonian contribution to
evolution values is the the kin
selection the inclusive fitness and that
sometimes what is known as hamilton's
rule that a trait will be favored uh if
the benefit times the relationship is
greater than the cost uh which is kind
of summed up in jb's holdings i laid
down my life for two brothers right
cousin quick the cost being that he
would lay down his life
exactly and that as a guiding principle
has been uh very helpful okay but i mean
are you alluding uh to the criticisms by
mathematicians in that are you alluding
to uh martin novak and tarnita and
wilson they had this paper about group
selection and you sociality a few years
ago that really stirred things up
it really quite did and
and i thought in some ways quite
exciting way i just started graduate
school when the paper came out and so
it's kind of been with me um your whole
life yeah ever since it was kind of one
of the first paper we read in general
club when i was a new grad student and
it kind of was really taken by by these
kind of conceptual uh debates and really
kind of reinvigorated my interest in
that part of the field so they in some
ways represent the latest iteration of
the debate they are far from the first
to make these kinds of criticisms of uh
inclusive fitness
um
they were kind of made from from the
get-go in a way that
given the centrality that is taken
it's not as mathematically robust as you
would want it uh to be
um but it's it's debate that perhaps has
calmed down a little bit the last few
years and i think we are in the field
once the dust has settled is better off
i think we're kind of more on the same
page of what the
limitations are and you can kind of have
a more i think a more interesting
discussion about when can you live with
those limitations and when can you not
um and um
kind of what the the the benefits of the
approach are and then i think i'm quite
comfortable with biologically using
different uh approaches depending on the
kind of temperament and kind of what
they want the model uh to achieve in a
specific situation but i guess i'm kind
of confused a little bit um because
the inclusive fitness idea i mean part
of what it wanted to do
at least in principle was to explain not
only why certain ants don't reproduce
and nevertheless
uh contribute to the life of the colony
but also maybe even altruism and human
beings or other other mammals and so
forth um
it sounds like it is quintessentially
mathematical like you you
haldane's joke is is very mathematical
right you know two brothers or or eight
cousins but you're saying that the
criticisms have come from the more
mathematically inclined why is that is
that explicable
uh so i think it's the
that there are part of the the concept
this kind of that relatedness is going
to be really important it's like a two
browsing it's in a way mathematical but
it's also quite
simple intuition so it led a lot of kind
of feel like you can go out and measure
what are the relatedness between
interacting individuals in this specific
population and kind of studying
that in a specific population in the
wild you can do it follow genetically by
comparing if you look at this group of
species that have developed this quite
complex social behavior do they have a
population structure of higher
relatedness so
you have interaction generally between
more relatives compared to this part of
this group of speeches on another part
of the file generic treaty yeah that do
they have less relatedness among
attracting individuals so it's kind of
guided us a lot in those kind of
approaches
and that kind of like kin selection
ideas there i think has been
they're mathematical but they're not
that
not too complex in a way they just kind
of point us in the right direction okay
now to get inclusive so
as i said but inclusive fitness
has
to its proponents
one of a kind of uniquely
good property of it is that it's a
property of the individual organism that
is and it can be modeled as a property
that an individual should appear as if
trying to maximize and this is
good uh because then you can kind of
treat it as the kind of design and
maximum of or design principle of
of evolution or natural selection that
um and this kind of goes back to some
part of evolution biology kind of the
key problem that we should try to
explain is the appearance of design that
like the kind of the fact that organs
appear so perfectly suited for the
environment that they live in that's
kind of adaptation or appearance of that
is the problem we should try to explain
yeah and you then take a step back and
say in order to do that we ought to have
a kind of a principle that shows like
what should organisms appear designed
for and to its performance and inclusive
fitness is that that organism should
appear at trying to maximize that and
you can kind of derive a model by which
you can get the expectation that that is
what organs should try to do to try to
do inverted commas
and that is that when you try to get
inclusive fitness to have that property
that it should be both but should try
and be maximized and be the property of
an individual
in order to get there the maths
is a little shakier in a way you have to
rely on more restrictions uh either to
get the work or the the assumptions are
considered to be almost the opposite
problem they're too general to really
become useful because they almost end up
it's kind of truism where it's always
true but there is where i think more
mathematically even more mathematically
minded people um
have had his criticisms um and i should
say all of these people are at you know
the massive end of the spectrum within
biology but you know if you come there
from a biologist by training interested
in theory versus someone who has the
original training in say maths of
physics and then
come into biology in graduate school or
even later on
um kind of
degrees of massiveness but and so again
just to get the landscape as it were
perfectly clear is the alternative to
inclusive fitness
uh
or is the alternative to kin selection
group selection or is it more
complicated than that
i'd say it's a alternative historically
that is often been kind of viewed as the
the two contrasts and what does it mean
selection
the group section again is one of those
terms that means different things to
different people and that is part of the
the
the problem
and
it has his story kind of meant to
slightly different things again coming
back to how we measure fitness
so by now
so i say kind of historically the first
way we thought of group selection wasn't
kind of well it's not often even by its
proponents referred to as naive group
selection this kind of fully that
individuals may sacrifice their life for
the good of the group really for the
good of the the species and that's often
kind of done in a rather unreflexive
kind of uh way
um but then you often define group kind
of group fitness in terms of groups
producing new daughter groups that like
you measure groupies in terms of new
groups uh produce
uh most today most models of group
selection so if you pick up a kind of
one of the current journals and someone
presents a group section mold fitness is
usually measured in terms of individuals
producing other individuals but that you
account for some sort of group property
some part of the group that's not really
reducible in a meaningful way into
individual level uh individual level
properties that is what now these days
meant by group selection i can sometimes
think that it's a little unfortunate
that that is became known as group
section but that is you know
me and others lost that debate a long
time ago uh that this is what we've
settled on as a field um but those
models can can
can often account for the same things
and often rely on similar kind of
properties
that a kin selection model would do
so one kind of observation or insight
that in some ways
calm things down in this kind of ongoing
debate between inclusive fitness and
group selection is that you can show
that often they are kind of formally
equivalent but they they give the same
prediction
um
and i think that that is a good thing to
realize that often you have the same
properties there's an interesting kind
of i think more philosophical point
there that
often this equivalence claim relies on
generating rather abstract statistical
models that you get almost quite far
removed from the kind of course causal
processes happening in order to achieve
that kind of equivalence and
i'm kind of two minds of this sometimes
i'm kind of thinking oh this is great
have we shown that they're equivalent
yeah sometimes i'm a little concerned
that like this equivalence relies on
such an abstract notion and that
surely we are interested in
what causally happen in a specific
event whether it is better described in
terms of inclusive fitness which is an
individual level property or in terms of
group level uh properties but good well
this is that's perfect segue because i
do want to finally hit the payoff here
which is that
you know once you start thinking about
things in this way evolution in this way
of population genetics and
equating my life to that of an
equivalent number of other people's
sharing the same genome uh that's when
you get to the jean's eye view right
that's when it begins to make maybe make
sense that what we should think of as
competing in the world of uh evolution
is different genes rather than different
organisms yeah i think the kind of the
origin story of the gene's eye view
which is a perspective that kind of
really comes to his own in the 1960s and
1970s stand on the exactly these three
topics that we have covered is a
approach to evolutionary biology that
takes adaptation as the central problem
that we're trying to explain
it builds on the insight from population
genetics that evolution can be described
as changes in allele frequencies
and then kind of the third debate from
which emerges is the one over group
versus individual level selection or the
kind of sometimes known as the broader
levels of selection
debates and in a way kind of combines
these three into one perspective
thinking that adaptation is what we are
trying to explain and kind of then goes
about thinking well
when they say that adaptation is for for
the good of something what is that
something and the answer to that then is
the the gene because genes then are
conceptualized as these entities that
are passed on intact from one generation
to the next whereas the kind of the main
alternative organisms or sometimes
groups don't have that evolutionary
longevity required to play that role an
organism by this reasoning is a unique
combination of its genotype and
environment and their interaction is
here in one generation gone in the next
whereas a gene then is passed on so by
this reasoning the gene is ultimate
beneficiary of any uh adaptation
and kind of lastly it
does this it kind of takes this insight
from population genetics that evolution
is this lineages of genes of a
generation but because it's very much
going to emerge out of this story study
of social behavior the kind of group
selection debate it combines that with a
form of kind of anti-morphosizing or
genetial thinking i think if if i was a
gene what would i do in this situation
and this is where it comes that we
expect genes to behave selfishly and
self simply meaning here trying to
maximize their own representation in the
next uh generation and just to give
credit words to the the idea obviously
became famous and was developed by
richard dawkins with a selfish gene but
the it was essentially the idea itself
was already there
yeah so i think most of us learned about
the genesis through the writings of
richard dawkins especially the the
selfish gene
uh ten years earlier the the american
george williams published a book called
adaptation and natural selection which i
hold as one of the most important books
in in evolutionary in the second half of
the 20th century
but this is a book primarily directed
towards other biologists and who on whom
it did have a kind of profound influence
it really sharpened the discussion about
adaptation and the study of uh
adaptation uh but it's you know you had
the kind of fate that
successful academic books have it's read
by uh the peers and and and
but not so much more uh whereas you know
there are a few terms in modern science
that have had as the reach that that
selfish genes
has had but to say many of those
arguments are there already 10 years
earlier but they are laid out in an even
more explicit and a much more forceful
way in in the selfish it's a much better
title come on
yeah it's an incredible title and uh it
matters right except that we're still
arguing about what's selfish and what
gene that means that still works that's
okay
the purpose of the title is to make
people buy the book so it's an
incredibly successful title in that
sense yeah that you have to admit and
just to be just to clarify what it means
to say the sort of uh i like that you
call it the the the jeans
uh sorry what did you call it i've
forgotten it uh
so it's a little bit you're lowering the
temperature a little bit from the
selfish gene uh way of putting it but um
i mean one distinction may be worth
drawing is that when we say gene here
and correct me if i'm wrong we mean the
instantiation of every single copy of
that particular gene in all the
individuals that's the thing that is
competing it's not like the particular
stretch of dna just in one cell or one
individual
exactly most of the time that that is
indeed what we mean um they're kind of
the in a way the the type the gene type
that is present or in this old copies in
in a population and you think of that
kind of whatever that is is trying to
maximize his own representation
uh it turns out that this way of
thinking in this kind of
gene's eye view is very effective at
also thinking of situations where indeed
the material part of a specific genes
are in conflict with other genes within
a body
what is known as this kind of genomic
conflicts in in biology where kind of
the fitness interests of different genes
inside an organism diverge and this is
kind of one of those empirical fears
that really was um stimulated by the
kind of shift in perspective from
organism down to the to the gene level
and one of the reasons why people
got their hairs up on end a little bit
uh and also one of the reasons why other
people love the idea is because it does
seem to anthropomorphize a little
abstract notion right i mean we
richard dawkins and uh no one else
believes that
genes have attitudes or have selfishness
or anything like that so the claim is
purported to be that given this
mathematical description
of population genetics and kin selection
inclusive fitness
it is as if the genes are being selfish
exactly i mean and the as if here is is
crucial right um especially because i
mean selfish
is of course a very loaded term and i
think you know dawkins preps deserve
some criticism that this the use of the
word selfish selfish even in the book
slides
a little bit what i mean because on the
one hand you have selfishness in terms
that all genes are expected to be
selfish yeah which and you can you can
say that if something applies to
everyone how useful is the term to begin
with
because you also then use the same word
to describe individual organisms
behaving selfish and you contrast that
with them saying behaving altruistically
or
uh or
mutualistically and and they're like
something that used slightly slightly
differently they kind of the essence
you kind of get it but it also kind of
slides somewhat and this is not even to
begin with the kind of psychological
motivations of of genes or organisms
where again we use just in kind of daily
language in a slightly though related
kind of way and is the gene's eye view
or the selfish gene idea supposed to be
exactly equivalent to the existing
formalism but just uh highlighting
things in a conceptually more clear way
or does it actually make slightly
different predictions
so most of the time the idea is that it
will be
the same that often so kind of in the
book that was followed up
followed the self machine the extended
phenotype which kind of uh is the only
book that richard dawkins wrote that was
aimed at professional biologists right
uh all of the books you know as you know
has been for the public but the extended
phenotype are for professional
biologists and it comes with it's fully
referenced as you can expect a book like
that to be
that being said it can be it's a book
that can be understood by anyone kind of
willing to make the effort but you get
less for free yeah that you compared to
his other books but there he starts with
kind of the the this necker cube
illusion that if you draw a cube on a
paper
with a straight line so you can often
see from two perspectives which lines
come
first so to speak
and he kind of would say that this in a
way is the gene centered versus the kind
of inclusive fitness view of the world
that there are kind of two ways of
looking at the same things
and in many ways that is the kind of
prevailing attitude i would say um early
on in the selfish team is written a bit
more that like this is a kind of
empirical rival to individual group
level selection um kind of
but i'd say most of the time it's
considered that it's
equivalent to inclusive fitness
and
i do
there is an interesting
kind of history about the relationship
between the gene side view and inclusive
fitness
as far as i can tell the very first time
that the term self machines appears is
in the notes that dawkins developed when
he was a graduate student and his phd
advisor was away on sabbatical and asked
him to step in and lecture on animal
behavior
and
is in the mid 1960s so the papers on
inclusive fitness had just been
published and dawkins wanted to cover it
but these are tricky papers to to get
right so he had tied up his notes
um and then there he kind of explains
the insight inclusive fitness using this
kind of gene-centric approach that we
should expect genes to behave selfishly
or trying to maximize their own
that being said um while dawkins has
kind of viewed hamilton as arguably the
greatest darwinian since darwin he's
also sometimes thought that hamilton is
one of those people who never really
finished their own revolution and never
committed fully to the to the inside
that you should just get rid of the
organism and go down to the genic
uh level uh so
the first answer is that yes they're
mostly time equivalent i think the more
the nuance answer is that there isn't
kind of i think under-appreciated
tension between gene side view and
exclusive fitness that um sometimes um i
think would be explored more
well so i was gonna ask
i was gonna ask about how you could get
new insights even if they were exactly
identical but but maybe i'm not clear on
how they're what the tension is you know
maybe there's rhetorical tension but is
there empirical tension
so the i'd say the tension arises that
um
the way we can if you want to construct
an inclusive fitness model that is a
kind of an individual
organism property
um and
that often you have to kind of ignore
things that happen inside of the
organism that like that all the whole
part of the audience share the same
purpose yeah it kind of has a unity of
purpose yeah um whereas so i've done
most of my empirical research has been
on these examples of genomic conflicts
so situations where genes differ in
their inner fitness interest where
that that assumption breaks down that
you don't have kind of all genes working
for the same goal you have certain genes
working for their own transmission even
if that comes at the expense of the
thickness of the individual
uh organism that carries it and these
are kind of passive somewhat confusing
in term that they're known as selfish
genetic elements which is you know
strikingly close to selfish genes but
here selfishness is then used in a much
more explicit way that they are selfish
with respect to
other genes of the same gene or indeed
the thickness of the individual
organisms i think i said here so the
question is who are the genes competing
with is it other alleles i mean the the
alleles that are competing so they are
competing with other alleles and other
organisms or
if really they just want to pass
themselves on who cares if other ones
are also passing themselves on they
might even fight against other genetic
components of their own organism
exactly and this this is truly a weird
and wonderful world and you have
examples like so you have things like
meiotic drivers that so normally you
expect that meiosis so the process of
production of sperms and eggs is this
kind of fair lottery that you have two
copies of a specific gene like in humans
and that each of them has a 50 chance of
being transmitted every time you produce
a sex cell but then you have these kinds
of genes that can distort that process
so kind of in general rather than ending
up in 50
of the the sex cells they end up in 90
95 99
of them and this can they can then
become very common in a population even
if that by doing so they reduce the
number of of offspring or in in other
words fitness of the individual in which
this kind of distortion happens
and you have also kind of almost any
part of the mechanism by which you copy
genes and put them into sex that has
been
uh hijacked by some sort of cytogenetic
element to to improve their chances of
being
transmitted and
i think these kind of things are make
in many ways make perfect sense from
from a gene center or a genesis right
new it's
often been considered kind of the
perfect kind of empirical vindication of
the uh the approach
uh and i think this kind of the
tradition in evolutionary biology that
emphasizes the individual organism
too much which i think i put inclusive
fitness in that category
i often have to downplay the importance
of this kind of phenomena too much for
for my liking okay it's not that you
can't use those approaches but in a way
it's kind of a
um
an initial temperament i think of what
kind of what observation you think are
important in trying to explain well it's
interesting because i forget whether we
said this explicitly but one of the
motivations or sort of paradigmatic
examples in
discussions of kin selection and
inclusive fitness are ant colonies right
where many individuals have no offspring
right depending on what kind of ant they
are you know they work for the
betterment of the colony and the idea
being that their genetic heritage is
passed down by them serving their queen
and their you know etc even though they
themselves don't have offspring and so
this is kind of a
twist on that idea we are saying that
a certain gene
can benefit itself it's maybe maybe it's
the it's the
it's the
evil twin of that idea a certain gene
can benefit itself by shutting down some
of the reproduction of uh reproductive
capacities of an organism but
guaranteeing that its cells or its uh
heritage will be passed on
yeah i mean and at the heart in some
ways you are faced with the same kind of
conceptual question and that you have an
allele that is harmful in a way to the
individual that carries it and you're
trying to make sense of how can that
ever evolve that kind of conundrum and
like that happens when you have the
evolution of sterility in working in new
social insects and in the situation of
these kind of genetic conflicts or
saltogenic elements that you have the
spread of alleles that's harmful to
individual character and so how that how
can we explain that evolutionarily uh so
to me there's always been that kind of
um conceptual kinship between the two
kinds of questions and and even if to go
back okay that was a very very
interesting um example there but even if
the two views like dawkins originally
said are more or less equivalent it
still can bring conceptual insight if
you have a different way of formalizing
the same set of ideas and so by thinking
of genes as the agents in some sense uh
you think of all biology is slightly
different right i mean there's this
whole vocabulary of
genes as replicators and organisms as
just the vehicles all the organisms are
our buses to carry on genes from
generation to generation
yeah in many ways that is the central
claim of the gene side view that
evolution by natural selection requires
two entities it requires something to
play the role of replicators which is
how
information is passed on
from one generation to the next and then
something that kind of packages that
and
is around and that is known as vehicles
or and this is typically a role
typically played by by organisms um but
in principle it can also be played by
things like like a cell like in
situations like cancer so there you have
kind of
the break down you used to have kind of
think of it as one vehicle now we have
some vehicles that have broken out on on
on their own competition and and in in
in in practice you can in principle you
can also be something like the whole
group could be could be the vehicle but
you're absolutely right that in a way
like the choice of words here it's
important that vehicle is kind of
inherently a passive term compare
relative to
uh the replicator you kind of clear kind
of what is valued in this viewpoint is
the becoming replicator and the organism
in a way is downplayed
and they kind of
dawkins
was part of formalizing this but it's
also the philosopher biology david hall
who kind of came up with same kind of
way of formalizing the the insight of
the gene sub view but he preferred the
term interactor over vehicle because you
think that by calling it vehicle you're
downplaying too much what's interesting
about uh organisms
uh to so it's um so
um
but dawkins famously said that he didn't
coin he coined the term vehicle not to
praise it but to bury it that he really
wanted kind of the field to move his
focus down too some of my best friends
are organisms i do want to give them
credit for you know for doing something
playing some role here but um it this is
probably out of left field but
that distinction kind of reminds me of
touring machines
a little bit you know the idea of some
physical or even just you know touring
machines is probably
uh being too high brow about it
computers right where you have hardware
and software um i've always wondered
going back to touring in his machines
where he has an instruction tape and
then some little head that goes back and
forth and does the job
um
how natural is this
division of labor into sort of
physical
doer in the world versus instructions or
information about how to do it i mean at
the end of the day it's all physical
stuff
uh
so where and why and how universal is
this
distinction um it seems certainly seems
central to the gene's eye view yeah i
mean and it's an interesting layer to
that that
dawkins himself seemed to be very taken
by computers he was one of the first to
kind of learn how to program a computer
at the department when he was a still an
active uh researcher
uh and in in several of his book it does
emphasize that
genes or dna has this kind of
information yeah just like
a cd or any kind of storage and then the
organism is this machine that own which
you just use rhymes
there is a debate in philosophy biology
to understand kind of the machine
metaphor is helpful or
not
and in the kind of thinking of organisms
as machines it goes back a long way and
i think historically has been quite
helpful
i'm
i'm a little bit of too much because i
think there is something interesting
about organisms because on the one hand
of course there are physical objects
just like everything else as you say
there is subject to the same laws of
physics like anything else and
um
there's nothing kind of magical about it
so their physical just like anything
else at the same time organisms are
physical objects unlike anything else
that they have in this kind of like
almost sometimes the
uh a sense of purpose or goal directing
is in them and like this is kind of what
given rise to kind of by all this uneasy
relation with teleology and that should
how much should we allow ourselves to
talk in terms of of purpose and that is
something that really runs quite deep in
in biology you can rile up even the most
senior and sober
people on questions like this whether
this is an embarrassment that we talk in
terms of or purposes in in biology
whereas others think that
it's almost impossible not to do it
especially when we study
animals and animals behaviors that kind
of attempts to try to use some sort of
language that's meant to be neutral
it's not just uh unhelpful it's
downright um silly um and pres my
my attitude is somewhat that
you can this has been the classic debate
that did darwin banish teleology from
from from biology or did he naturalize
it right that didn't make it okay by
kind of natural selection it's a way
that makes their cake because then you
can talk about goals and purpose in
terms of
uh of fitness
and in a way kind of like i think of the
kind of inclusive fitness tradition in a
way coming from that
naturalizing way that like here you have
kind of something that organisms ought
to kind of appear as striving towards so
there's no magic here there's no land
vital there's nothing kind of spooky
going on but you have kind of allow
yourself to use a kind of language that
otherwise isn't really okay in science i
mean you don't really you don't use it
in in in in physical chemistry
part of science that biology often looks
towards uh but biology i think straddles
this studies on one end is a physical
science but they understand the
behavioral science and it's awkwardly
trying to balance uh the two but it's
certainly i think the part of science
where purpose enters into our
explanation in one way or another
and i am on the view that we should just
accept that but try to do it in a you
know formalize or try to be so kind of
as
formal about it as possible in the way
we approach uh approach it yeah good i'm
completely on your side uh i have hopes
to write
i've already written in in various
places
toward the s side that says that
uh
purpose and teleology can be naturalized
basically i would say not just because
of evolution but because of the arrow of
time because of entropy increasing over
time but to do it i say it can be
naturalized i didn't say that i did it
or you know we have a formal theory of
it and i think that that's something
that it would be very interesting to
understand better than we do
yeah it's a a colleague of mine minus
pat and i just submitted a paper where
we try to defend what we call licensed
anthropomorphizing oh good which is kind
of a concept that you should you're
allowed to anthropomorphize and say if i
was a gene
i would do so and so yeah but then you
need to back it up with a with a model a
mathematical model and that is what
provides the license that
and any kind of goes back to the inside
this basic point that is almost
impossible to do biology without using
this right but we should try to do that
then in a kind of an organized or
licensed kind of way and that we argue
is kind of things like mathematical
population genetics or other
parts of um mathematical biology
provides that license to do so i would
say personally the same exact things
about free will but let's not get into
that uh debate right now that's for
another discussion um then there's that
let me give you one more chance um just
in case we've missed anything
to
uh
give
good consequences of being a jeans i
view jean's eye view person or selfish
gene person like are there other
predictions that this viewpoint leads us
to or other perspectives that are
helpful to biology
so
i think that the gene sub view is a it's
a very powerful thinking tool in biology
i think it's one of the best tools we
have to make sense of this messy world
but like with all tools to get the most
out of it you must understand where it
came from and what it was what is trying
to achieve
um so it's an approach and then to try
to understand uh adaptations and kind of
the logic of natural selections that can
give rise to that yeah so it works
especially well when those adaptations
of your observing are kind of
counterintuitive to the individual
organisms point of view which has been
the traditional focus of biologists so
we talked a little bit about genomic
conflicts as i think it's a great
example of where that the benefits of
the genes of you come through the others
in the study of social behavior they
understand the workers reality
and one that was kind of like a new
thing that people handle is the notion
of extended phenotypes so these are
defined as phenotypes that are located
outside of the body in which the the
genes that are going to cause
responsible for that phenotype uh reside
so kind of typical example has been the
the things that animals build like the
beavers dam or
the um nests of birds so these kind of
structures that clearly has a genetic
component to them but and so in a way
should be thought of as a phenotype but
that
the phenotype is not part of the
organism so wait did do the clothes i
wear count as my extended phenotype
uh so the scenarios are typically
considered to be to be part that has
some influence on on the fitness of the
organism in kind of a
consistent way across uh time and
population i think it's pretty clear
that how well people dress has an impact
on their uh reproductive success
and they do though uh
humans are famously in a apparent
species to study
i'm just gonna leave this on purely
periodical grounds don't worry
yeah yeah um but uh those kind of build
structures of animals i think that kind
of like thinking of dome those in turn
from from a genie point of view i think
helped stimulate that also kind of um
individuals
uh where
individuals of one species can
manipulate the behavior of another so
kind of this gruesome for example like
zombie ants where yeah ants who are
infected by a particular kind of fungi
completely change their behavior from
kind of shying away from parts of
the the planet where they live to go
where it's beneficial for the
uh for the fungi to live and eventually
kind of
end up behaving completely uh bonkers
because of their being affected by this
um this fungi and here so that again
there's a behavior of the ant that has a
genetic component but the genes of for
that for if you will if you allow us of
that shorthand for that behavior is not
located in the ant it's located in
another organism and that again is
something that this kind of extended
phenotypes are i think easier to think
about from a genic point of view than
trying to
shoehorn it into that of uh the
individual uh
organism
so except let me let me you know bring
up uh
that not everyone agrees right like this
is why you wrote a book because there
are skeptics and and critics of the
gene's eye view point of view and
at least i mean hopefully you'll fill me
in on what all the critics are the most
important critics are but one of them is
uh that even the modern synthesis is no
longer how we should be thinking about
evolution right i mean there's uh
horizontal gene transfer there's uh
epigenetic factors uh the whole idea
that there's just a simple tree and
things branch off and never cross
pollinate has been become a lot messier
in recent years there's mitochondrial
dna as well as nuclear dna so
is there any uh legitimacy to this idea
that
the gene's eye view is just a
codification of a very old-fashioned way
of thinking about evolution
it the genes-eye view certainly uh
shares a lot with the the modern
synthesis especially kind of ideas that
adaptation and natural selection are
important and kind of framing that in
terms of genes
um but there are a couple of things i
think that are worth mentioning here so
one that the modern synthesis is perhaps
more also more diverse than what critics
of it gave it credit for they often
presented as this very kind of
strict dogmatic viewpoint which it
wasn't included many different kinds of
people many different kinds of
views
second of all criticism of it has
existed pretty much as soon as it was
kind of codified or kind of as a became
expressed that often of the the the
nature i think of people not really
thinking that what they study gut did
this the respect that it deserved sure
uh and this has come different kind of
versions of this uh over over time
uh i think it is interesting both
richard dawkins and george williams so
the kind of the the two architects of
the dean's review did emphasize that
they what they were doing it was to kind
of articulate the kind of orthodox view
in a new way that they kind of very much
align themselves with that kind of
traditional uh
approach
um so the
larger criticism of the modern synthesis
and the inside view often is taken to be
kind of the poster child of that is that
biology has changed so much that is all
way of thinking about is no longer
helpful right
and
yeah this is a contentious topic and and
and and i think many
sensible people can disagree on it i i
don't tend to think tend to view this
this new observation as being lethal to
the modern synthesis in any way i think
it's modern it's also quite a it's a
flexible framework and evolution by all
is not as dogmatic as even its internal
critics would like it to present it but
it's been quite successful at
incorporating
it
and we are probably putting too much
emphasis on certain things and not
enough emphasis on on other things
and perhaps the kind of the greatest
challenge i think to the dean's view is
these notions of
that we ought to consider a more
inclusive notion of inheritance that we
are giving genes too big of a role in
that that parents pass on more to their
offspring than their genes so this can
be things like
epigenetic signals methylation patterns
but also kind of cultural
forms of cultural inheritance some other
kinds of
maternal
effects
um so that i think there's there may
well be some truth too
um one thing that i would call it like
to see i don't know if anyone has done
is that
the reason why
the genesis proponent likes to talk
about replicators rather than genes if
that replicators is completely divorced
divorced from any sort of material basis
and that what really matters is that it
can make copies of itself so i wonder
how some of these kind of other forms of
inheritance can that can that be
incorporated into this kind of
traditional frame framework i mean
certainly richard dawkins is in favor of
thinking about memes as an important
method of uh cultural transmission
and yeah i mean memes also is i think
it's interesting is of course it was
coined in the last chapter of the the
first edition of the selfish gene it was
meant to kind of free
um replicate it from the kind of
association with
genes in a way and that was the idea
that if organic evolution requires
something to play a replicator and a
vehicle so should cultural evolution
uh and do ironically though i think that
the
despite wanting to free itself from the
material basis of genes it is actually
exactly those kinds of properties that
that makes the genes hiv work so well in
organic evolution but not in cultural
evolution yeah that things that you know
where does one gene start and the other
one ends how long is a gene what does
mutation actually look like or
computation between alleles what are
really a lot of things that
in organic everything we try to downplay
some of those kind of properties but in
a way that is kind of exactly why it
worked at the end of the day in organic
evolution but not in in cultural
evolution where those violence becomes
so poor is that i think i think to to to
lose it's it's it's value as a concept
yeah a real biological gene is something
at the end of the day you can hope to
point to there in the dna
yeah it's anchored in some sort of
material reality in a way that i think
is hard to do in memes that so despite
being a very successful meme in of
itself my impression is that it's yeah
it's influencing current study of
culturally somewhat limited um
that makes sense i think i guess and
this is a good place to sort of wrap up
um
the part of the discussion that is that
is most fascinating to me has taken us a
while to get here but it's the level of
selection levels of description
discussion right um one thing that one
can say it's not a very useful thing to
say but one can say it is if i could be
laplace's demon if i if i knew the exact
state of everything in the universe and
i knew all the laws of physics and i had
infinite calculation of
i could just tell you what was going to
happen and i think an underappreciated
aspect of that is that laplace's demon
doesn't need to know about cells and
genes and organisms right it just needs
to know about the microscopic state of
the world but i can talk about things in
terms of cells and and genes or
organisms or societies etc
is there how i mean this is a far too
big question to answer but uh
say what it inspires you to say what is
the right way to think about
the different levels of description that
we have to capture um biological reality
and
can they coexist or is there a best one
that we should focus in on
i think i very much
come on the view these days that there
isn't one best way to do it in biology i
think that biology is a kind of science
that
is so messy and especially departure by
all the like evolution where we're
trying to understand the historical
process that we are better off trying to
retain
multiple uh perspectives
um and that so i'm quite comfortable
that some people prefer to model things
in a group selection way and some in an
inclusive fitness kind of way and
sometimes in a general kind of way and
that like
that is not necessarily going to be a
true answer that well there may be one i
don't know it's meaningful necessarily
to spend all our time trying to to find
that
that being said i think we ought to
spend some time worrying about when we
have two different kinds of approaches
so one example is practicing so in
population genetics and inclusive
fitness methodology so inclusive fitness
you've often relied on these kind of
optimization methods quite popular in
the study of behavior animal behavior
uh but optimization is also something
that population genetics is rejected in
the 1960s that that we should never
expect selection to optimize anything
that is that so i think it's going to be
in this kind of may recent equilibrium
but they're not going to be kind of
optimized in any sort of meaningful way
so
some part of our field has rejected it
and some uses constantly um and i in
some ways i'm fine with that at some
time i think we ought to spend some time
worrying about it
uh
but kind of on the larger philosophical
point i i think that we have
you know as you i think you have one
reality but you have many ways of
talking about it and i think that
becomes expressed uh you know
very well on a day-to-day level in the
study of biology well i guess the
complication or the interestingness of
the question comes in because
well for me personally i don't know
about for the rest of the world but
since someone as someone who is trained
on pretty cut-and-dried examples of
different levels of of descriptions such
as atoms and fluids right we can
literally derive fluid mechanics from
large collections of atoms interacting
with each other and we know that you
don't need to understand atoms to
understand fluids or vice versa
so there's this
almost too good to be true simplicity of
autonomy of the different levels and i
get the feeling i'm sort of slowly
dawning to the realization that in
biology and in the
human sciences
that those levels are harder to
disentangle from each other
i think i think that is that is exactly
right that you you have these kind of
layers of descriptions that both can
work really quite well so kind of the
quantitative genetics that animal
readers use where you're kind of
selecting on phenotypes and you kind of
know that there's
heritability because you can compare
parents and offspring but the kind of
quite precise quantitative methods that
you use there
don't really care about
the dna sequences necessarily they can
be informed by those and i think like
you know with the advance of what you
know sequencing and all that that part
has also been improved but it functions
rather well without it as well but it's
not that sort of you can kind of derive
those kind of phenotypic approaches from
studying
genetic sequences or vice versa it's not
necessarily gonna happen i think uh
and i don't really feel that pessimistic
saying that i think that's just kind of
the nature of the the endeavor
um so
absolutely i think biology is kind of
perhaps when that kind of
that you can derive one from that is
starting to really break down well i
think but i think i think i certainly
agree with that a hundred percent but
there there's sort of like a
deeper trickier issue i mean i think
that far too much emphasis has been put
on derivability because outside the very
simplest examples of course you can't
derive i cannot derive the solidity of
the table in front of me from the
standard model of particle physics but i
don't think it's incompatible with that
right um but what is important i think
or not is what is important what i'm
what i'm interested in at the moment is
i don't need to know about the standard
model of particle physics to describe
the behavior of the table there is an
autonomous theory of it and in biology
forgetting about derivability it's not
even clear to me that there's that right
like yeah no
that's an interesting point i don't
thought about it that way but yes i
think there is there's
less clear that you have that kind of a
symmetry yeah no i think i think that is
absolutely true that you can kind of go
about it
um
i mean everything has to be compatible
of course what's going on exactly at the
lower level but like how that
how do you even begin to kind of worry
about that i think it's less clear
well i mean i have a i have an example
in mind which is very contemporary which
is uh the germ theory of disease right
so you know we can have a theory of how
diseases are transmitted through
breathing and contact and things like
that without actually knowing that
they're microbes
right you know we don't need that lower
level theory but it is helpful and so i
i i honestly don't know the answer to
this question but i would like to know
uh is there some sense in which
there is a self-contained theory of you
know let's say disease transmission that
never refers to microbes or if there is
such a thing is it so baroque and
backwards that you should always you can
always improve your description by just
allowing helping yourself to the
microbial description
yeah i guess part of the answer my line
that like epidemiological models
are in some ways very generic in the
sense that you rely on like it just
transmitted from one individual to the
next but they can certainly improve by
knowing how it's transmitted so like
learning that
the cov19 rise is primarily airborne
rather than like staking around on
surfaces improves models
i think uh in kind of how you want to
let it become more
uh exact but you can certainly
it's not necessarily
you can do
sound models regardless of how that how
they kind of transmission what is most
important for transmission on this
particular uh
virus but it's kind of where one part
where the biology of it uh matters or
kind of the reality of it yeah i do
think these are these are good questions
we don't know the answers to yet so but
i'll give you one last chance uh one
final question what what is all this uh
bode for the future of evolutionary
biology like it's interesting to me as
an outsider to see the
flare-ups not just intellectual but
emotional when things like the uh novak
at all paper came out about group
selection or
uh just the discussion around the idea
of the selfish gene you know it gets
pretty heated um you've mentioned a
couple times that data has sort of
stepped in and
and made things a little calmer uh is
that the future or are we still in for
you know a whole bunch of uh heated
debates and the pages of the new york
review books
um
i think the data certainly has helped a
lot um but there is also this issue that
um that in evolution about that we tend
to have these flare-ups over time
there was a fun paper probably a couple
of years ago called simply called what
is wrong with evolutionary biology
um and that's that the kind of the
argument there is that they think
they're kind of
two things that evolution financial
section under one is such an abstract
principle that it can kind of be applied
to almost anything
but also the evolution biology is such a
diverse field in terms of what we study
yeah so if you can't convince the
paleontologist maybe you can get the
molecular genesis to listen to you if
they don't maybe you can try the plant
ecologists and that those two things in
combination mean that you can always get
a small enough audience to keep it going
but you also may have a lot of time yeah
explaining like kind of convincing
everyone
kind of the chief thing that i hope to
achieve with this book is to bring
some nuance to the debate over the gene
side view that i noticed that one that
people kept having these debates
but also when i kind of when i was a
graduate student i would ask
more senior people in my department
about it you know you walk to one person
and they will tell you oh yeah this is
um
this is the correct way to think about
evolution and everyone knows that and
then you walk a few doors down and you
say oh no this was debunked in the 70s
and everyone knows right and i kind of
there was something there that i kind of
was frustrated both by the proponents
and the the critics that i often thought
that they painted kind of an unfair um
picture of what the debate actually is
kind of the strength of the case both
for and against this way of thinking
about about the evolution and so that's
kind of what i wanted to capture really
with the book yeah no i think it's great
i think this was extremely helpful
conversation for me in clarifying things
so maybe maybe whatever debates we have
in the future they'll be at least on a
more informed basis going forward so
arvid ogre thanks so much for being on
the weinstein podcast thank you very
much for having me
[Music]
you